so Michael Bolton young legend what do
people call you like what are your
friends are they calling you like Mike
well now they call me young legend since
you started it do they call you on the
wall I bring them in for LASIK surgery
so they can fix their eyes that's very
sweet of you though
I think when people started referring
and especially traveling around the
world during promotion yeah the first
time I heard legend connected with my
name I thought wow I must behold no you
have to be in the business for a long
time and hopefully be successful for a
long time and then I thought oh that's a
good thing it's a good thing it is young
legend is even you know almost an
oxymoron but it's very acceptable nice
to hear does anyone call you the bolt
bolt actually there are people who call
me at the bolt I like Sam Baily from
England from the x-factor
oh the x-factor yeah she calls me the
bolt mile/h calls me for input and
advice about things great singer yeah
yeah so let's talk about the new album a
symphony of hits it is so classy what
made you want to bring the orchestra
long for something like this well I
wanted to do something completely
different so I did something so classy
yeah I'm just good I have recorded you
know quite a few different genres of
music and kind of places in time my own
visit back to Hitsville where Motown was
born and then at one point on the 90s I
got invited to sing with Luciano
Pavarotti and I was I kind of said that
sound you just made yeah and I was a
nervous wreck about it was so excited
and then I spoke to him on the phone and
he said Mike I was so glad you are
joining us and I think we will do these
two songs and you mentioned the arias
never heard of either one of them didn't
know the melodies had no idea yes kind
of panicked I said how would you feel
about Nessun Dorma and vesti la Juba and
he said brilliant genius we shall do
them but it was like it felt like a half
hour before he answered but it was
three seconds what did I just ask adieu
the master the maestro yeah and I
started preparing to sing with him and I
was listening to his greatest hits while
promoting my own music around the world
I would go back into my dressing room
and put
Pavarotti's greatest hits on and my eyes
would well up because this is someone
who was given one of the greatest gifts
any singer has ever had and then took
that gift and made it even greater and I
was studying the nuances and diminuendo
and things that I don't have to think
about but now I'm thinking of myself as
a tenor and as a tenor you have to
really take care of your voice you have
to study of singing in Italian and
French and Spanish and yeah
but with him I had two Italian arias to
learn and it was life altering and he
was so generous with me and gracious and
I kind of fell in love with the arias
and you needed a big orchestra for the
artists so we performed Princess Diana
was in the front row right in front of
me
Wow so that was amazing she was loved
that she was so gracious and you you
know why everybody falls in love with
her when they meet her and she was
raising money for children at the same
time of course so that was a big event
and I think that really got me going
towards an orchestra and my greatest
hits there's a lot of there a lot of
songs that were very successful
fortunately thankfully and I met with
one of my favorite arrangers in Los
Angeles it's kind of well a lot of
people use them for a lot of different
types of music Chris Walden and he said
I think we could do these in like six
days I could write the arrangements if
you'll come by the studio and give me
your input and we work day and night on
the arrangements flew to Perth Australia
where I had a tour planned right after
this recorded the entire Orchestra and
then toured Australia with the orchestra
with a full orchestra Wow and now we
just want to hear it every night now
it's weird when we don't have an
orchestra but sonically and thematically
it's sweeping beautiful
uplifting very rich and I love it yeah
Joey talks more no the Lonely Island
guys yeah maybe Lord boltron I like that
I don't know why but they seem to get a
kick out my drop so I'll get emails from
them very funny after all these years is
there a song that you just can't stand
or you're just tired of like oh do I
have to sing this or hear this no I
really I'm not tired of any of the hits
through the years I'm so grateful for
them and because of the story I was
telling you and I didn't make it up it
took me 18 years to have the hit and I
began writing songs for other artists as
well when I get to my body of work of
the greatest hits it's more like every
once in a while that's not where I feel
comfortable vocally there's something
demanding about that song at that time
and I'm not feeling like you relate to
this as a singer you know what your top
notes are when you're if you warm up
before you sing yeah which I hope you do
that gives you a kind of ballpark of
where your voices and a comfort zone
hopefully but when you're work if you
feel like you're working a little harder
to get certain notes that should be like
that yeah that might make me change the
set list which I can do we call them
audibles
and I just go look at my guitars and go
talk of the bay talk of the bay he
starts to panic then he speaks into a
microphone that only the musicians can
hear talk of the bay talk of the bay
talk of the bay everybody starts turning
their pages and there are many
orchestras turning their pages it's
quite funny so there's not one that I
I'd read or I'm tired of if I get tired
of the arrangements we tweak them and
that's no problem we can make them
different and fresh yeah but with the
orchestra the symphony it's it's just
staggering it's so beautiful
advice for your younger self or you know
advice for you know the Justin Bieber's
or you know Shawn Mendes people who are
at the start of their 50 year right
well both really talented artists Justin
I think has gotten through I think and
hope like the tougher parts of making it
when you're young and have so much
talent that when you have that much of a
gift of voice in songwriting abilities
it can you can take it for granted that
it's going to continue and what we learn
is it doesn't just continue by itself
it's hard work great work ethic and
really taking care of your instrument
basically living like this is a gift
that I never want to lose and I always
want to maximize and that means taking
your work seriously and your downtime
seriously as well yeah lose the
distractions as much as you can yeah
let's talk about this fragrance time
love and tenderness so what does the
bolt smell like and if you smelt this on
a lady walking by would you be like you
know I hope so how long has it been
since you're showered that's a tough
question for me I hope I smell good
always I'd I think if I have to think
about it and something I've been working
too many hours you see I smell like Lord
Bolton like yeah what's wrong how does
Lord Bolton smile yeah delightful
delightful delightful Valentine's Day is
coming up and you are you know the
romantic mm-hmm that's kind of the vibe
I'm getting
there's some irony in this this
particular Valentine's Day so are you
alone in this Valentine what time is it
I have no plans in the foreseeable
future I'm on the I'm on the road I'm on
tour and I realize because a friend of
mine said so what are you gonna do where
are you for Valentine's Day and and like
they have a fiance and like everybody
know is planning on something romantic
I'm on tour with my band and crew yeah
we'll find a place generally we find a
great place to have dinner where you can
just have our own area to ourselves but
right now yeah as as I speak no date for
Valentine's Day I'm dateless for Michael
okay first of all it a little busy too
so there's dating apps you know slide in
the DMS yeah do any of that you have
time we have time like there's time to
do this would you do how you ever slim
anyone's DMS before sorry
no no to to iconic for that I think to
be slighted I got to stay young legend
speaking of Instagram you are showing
off your workouts on there oh yeah
looking good got a great trainer and I
just need your time the time me the time
yeah look I mean what a twirl that's
great because you can find a good gym
yeah in every city of the world and it's
five days a week pretty full-on how much
can you lift do you have a number
um I'm thinking of something funny
there's something funny in here I really
don't I don't lift for for a number yeah
I'm trying to get just a lot of
definition oh for the gram right for the
gram for Instagram Oh for the ground no
we're going to the Grammys or very
inappropriately of course I would say
the gram and you would think the gram
easier so I called a gram I know I need
to be on all of that so some great shots
on there yeah that was just a funny one
but yeah my trainer turns people into
movie stars